pour soi marielle de sarnez soir alors
vous êtes 10 présente du modem numéro
deux comme on dit actuellement bras
droit de françois bayrou député européen
comme en parlant des banques européennes
absolument évidemment dire alors quand
on parle du très bon score de la droite
au premier tour d'essai l'ump on dit
parfois celles des élus des on-dit
rarement ump udf modem
à la vérité ce score de 30% qui était un
bon score dans le sens koussa mais cette
coalition en tête mais qui est pas
encore exceptionnel c'est un score qui
rassemble extrêmement large savez il ya
des équipes de quatre personnes dans ces
équipes nous par exemple dans à peu près
un quart des cantons nous avons été
présents dans ces rassemblements qui
sont des rassemblements larges de l'ump
du modem avec des sans étiquette avec
des divers et c'est donc dans ces 30%
nous sommes bien sûr l'angola pourtant
tajo font de ce que vous avez réussi à
oublier de faire le pourcentage si vous
avez des équipes de quatre qui ont par
exemple chacun une étiquette différentes
dedion mr l'intérieur a même pas essayé
c'est quasiment impossible alors dans
les sondages
on le sait françois bayrou apparaît
toujours comme l'un des deux dirigeants
d'opposition toujours les mieux placés
toujours derrière alain juppé son ami
justement alain juppé dont françois
bayrou affirme être un proche soutien
est ce que c'est une alliance de
circonstance ont vu des primaires de
2016 et donc de la présidentielle de
où est ce qu'on va vers une vraie
coalition entre l'ump et des partis du
centre
la vérité si on regarde l'état du pays
j'ai entendu ce que vous disiez à
l'instant ce qui était dit à l'instant
sur les chiffres du déficit c'est vrai
qu'on a une tête qui continue de monter
et c'est vrai qu'on a une dépense
publique
c'est un chiffre important qui continue
d'augmenter on est passé de 55% à 57 de
la gueule quelque chose et puis on a
surtout les indicateurs du chômage qui
sont absolument terribles je suis
députée européenne je peux vous dire que
la france est quasiment c'est le seul
grand pays d'europe où on perd des
emplois depuis un an et à chypre
tu en perds aussi et puis nous qui
voyons le chômage augmente et ou vendu
plus de 5 millions de français au
chômage et tout ça
c'est quand même con annoncé tout à
l'heure j'ai des regrets se réjouir et
le japon n'aura de la création d'emplois
le jour on aura de la traction d'emplois
je crois absolument pas qu'on ait fait
les efforts de réformes structurelles
pour réduire au fond la dépense publique
parce que c'est ça la question
c'est d'avoir un état qui gère mieux
mais qui dépensent peut-être de façon
plus utile mais si je dis tout ça c'est
pour aller à la question vous avez
posées moi ma conviction profonde c'est
que pour au fond répondre aux attentes
des français pour apporter à nouveau de
l'espoir et l'espérance
il faudra des rassemblements larges il
faudra sortir de cette espèce
d'affrontements qu'on a depuis 30 ans
contre caen droite contre gauche gauche
contre droite qui fait que élection
après élection bas les gens sont dans
les désillusions aucune promesse n'ai
jamais tenus et surtout il n'ya plus
d'efficacité de l'action publique et je
vous salue marie s'est pas avéré
extrêmement à seulement 3 par c'est pour
ça que les extrêmement bien sûr meillard
désespérant aux autres exactement
l'important c'est donc eux politiquement
je crois que c'est très important de
vouloir que ça bouge de vouloir des
rassemblements larges à la limite
d'alain juppé jusqu'à des sociaux
démocrates réformistes et réformateurs
en passant par le centre et par françois
bayrou démocrates réformistes et bien il
y en a un tout petit peu à macron par
exemple oui mais bon vous voyez
regardez le mal qu'il a eu avec une loi
qui pour moi aller dans le bon sens mais
que tout le monde a refusé de voter
grosso modo celle d'une grosse partie de
la gauche ça veut dire que la gauche
elle est toujours pas dans un réformisme
depuis qu'elle a toujours pas fait son
son agenda mentaux la droite a refusé de
voter alors que dans cette loi il y
avait des choses que la droite réclamé
depuis des années des années et le
centre meilleurs ne l'a pas votée à
l'assemblée ce que j'ai pas compris
bon tout ça c'est une manière de faire
de la politique qui ne fonctionne pas il
va falloir pour redresser le pays
faire un peu presque fraudeurs avait fui
en allemagne il est arrivé avec quelques
objectifs précis qui ont été soutenues
par ba une un espace large centrale
large mais pour tout cela
marielle de sarnez faut que les hommes
et les femmes soient d'accord c'est très
pourtant on a l'impression que l'homme
fort de l'ump c'est à dire nicolas
sarkozy veut bien d'une petite alliance
comme ça avec lui dire problème avec le
modem éventuellement mais pas françois
bayrou parce qu'en fait tous ces élus au
fond qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
fait des rassemblements avec le modem
dans leur département parce que voilà
ces principes de réalité
il n'oublie pas non plus que j'ai pas de
problème avec le modem mais j'en ai
françois bayou bon écoute et honnêtement
je pense que tout ceci n'est pas à la
hauteur des défis qui sont devant nous
moi j'ai pas des problèmes avec sarkozy
chez des différents je pense qu'il n'a
pas fait tout à fait ce qu'il aurait dû
faire quand il était président de la
république
je pense que s'il avait réformé en
profondeur le pays bas on n'en serait
peut-être pas là aujourd'hui donc au
fond il ya une co responsabilité des uns
et des autres est là aujourd'hui dans
les tags dans l'opposition parce que
pendant longtemps les moi j'habitais pas
du tout pesé pas du tout moi je pense
que le parti à beyrouth propose de voter
en 2012 pour françois hollande disons
les choses
moi je me suis pas retrouvé nous ne
sommes pas retrouvés dans la connaît que
nicolas sarkozy parce que nous pensions
que au fond il était passé je trouve à
côté de choses qu'ils auraient pu être
utiles pour le pays s'il avait fait des
très bonnes choses pour le pays dans un
esprit d'apaisement dans un esprit au
fond d'union nationale moi je suis pas
de son parti mais j'aurais voté pour lui
volontiers mais j'ai fait partie comme
des millions de français
tu au four - ne s'y sont pas retrouvés
et qui sont pas pour autant de gauche
oui mais qui va écouter d'abord françois
hollande aurait pu être au fond 1
un président de la république prenant
les problèmes à bras le corps il ne l'a
pas fait je lui en veux énormément
c'est un reproche comme j'en veux à ses
prédécesseurs de la même façon et je
considère moi que le parti socialiste
n'est pas la réponse aux problèmes
d'aujourd'hui
regardez la dégradation économique et
social du pays
donc oui je pense que la sanction qui
était dans les urnes dimanche dernier de
la gauche du parti socialiste tel qu'il
est c'est à dire qui au fond ne se
transforme pas ne se réforme pas ne
votre même pas pour la loi macron je
pense que tout ceci sera confirmé dans
les urnes dimanche
elle descendait à titre personnel vous
ne donnez pas de consignes à vos
électeurs
panini pour vous pas de vote républicain
non plus je me retrouve pas dans le ni
ni
en tous les cas ça si l'humanité je ne
retrouve pas dans nos amis je pense
qu'il faut qu'il faut voter pour le
candidat qui a qui porte les valeurs
humanistes je mets pas un signe égal au
fond entre les candidats de l'extrême
droite et les candidats et vous laisser
du champ démocrate de lecture libre ça
c'est notre position depuis toujours de
deux de ne pas être pour le ni ni un
donc effectivement je ne mets pas un
signe égal
après les prêts bien que les électeurs
ils sont grands et évidemment c'est à
eux de décider
mais moi je considère que les
responsables politiques hommes et femmes
politiques
bah ils doivent prendre des positions
c'est aussi l'honneur de la politique
que de prendre des positions et donc est
dans le ni ni je trouve pour moi c'est
pas une position alors à propos du front
national vous avez déclaré que la force
de le mettre au centre de tout le centre
de koné c'est bien mais à le mettre au
centre de dubaï ont fini par faire son
lit et on fait sa campagne
est ce que vous avez dit c'est valable
pour vous pour manuel valls comme pour
nicolas sarkozy vous plus pour manuel
valls que nicolas sarkozy je pense que
d'abord on a eu une campagne qui est
passé complètement à côté de l'enjeu de
la campagne
c'est à dire qu'on a eu en fait une
campagne nationaliser une campagne
partisane extrêmement politicienne qui
est passé mais totalement à côté des
enjeux au fonds de gestion départemental
me faut dire qu'on ne savait pas
exactement je vais vous avez bien raison
en plus quand même franchement là les
socialistes ils ont exagéré parce que ce
sont des réformes qui coûte zéro euro de
repenser une architecture locales
départementales et régionales qui ait du
sens qui soit lisible pour les français
et au lieu de ça je dois dire que ça a
été un brouillard total ils ont dit on
va supprimer les départements
après on les supprime plus simplement
certains on ne connaît pas les
compétences
elles sont même pas voter à côté de ça
on fait des grands paris des métropoles
des agglos des intercoms en redécoupe
les régions bref tout ça est un
cafouillage qui départ honorable
alors oui c'est passé à côté des
départementales et je le regrette et en
même temps moi je me retrouve pas dans
une espèce de d'ultra politisation très
partisane de ces élections je trouve
c'est une échéance locale dans laquelle
d'ailleurs le lait
qu'ils viennent voter ils cherchent des
femmes et des hommes qui voient en
charge de leurs problèmes d'une
politique de proximité et c'est d'abord
la qualité humaine d'ailleurs qu'ils
cherchent c'est pour ça que nous avons
d'ailleurs de bons candidats noirs et
les 100 days justement qui est le leader
naturel du centre on n'arrive pas bien à
se repérer ses forces au pérou c'est la
garde si morin c'est borloo
mais plus qu'un faux qui allie deux je
vous dis encore il ya deux personnalités
plus la personnalité un qui se retrouve
comme authentiquement du centre plus
j'en saurai heureuse authenticité
sentent beaucoup de gens dans le même
marigot et ne sait jamais très mais
beaucoup de gens semblent il faut être
capable
écoutez franchement de dépasser les
clivages regardez l'état du pays
regardez l'état du monde regardez même
l'état de l'europe
je veux dire si on n'est pas capable de
pouvoir être entre responsables
politiques à ce rosso modo serrer les
coudes et se dire qu'on voudrait être
utile au pays
ensemble c'est qu'il faut arrêter de
faire de la politique donc oui il ya une
manière très politicienne de falla
poétique moi je la récuse complètement
je pense que d'ailleurs les français en
ont soupé qu'ils en ont marre qu'ils en
ont ras-le-bol et qu'il faut que les
hommes politiques changent et c'est
pourquoi quand quelqu'un comme françois
bayou qui évidemment incarne le centre
dit ben je suis prêt à m'entendre avec
quelqu'un qui pas de ma famille
politique parce que j'ai de l'estimé du
respect qui est alain juppé parce qu'on
peut construire des choses là souffle et
les goûts parce qu'on peut construire
des choses large et bachoo ça
intelligent je trouve que c'est bien de
dépasser un petit peu la réflexion même
beaucoup la réflexion purement partisane
ça veut dire que françois perrot quoi
qu'il arrive ne sera pas un candidat
pour la 4ème fois savez nancy cela veut
dire que si alain juppé
si alain juppé est choisi à l'issue de
la primaire je pense que nous pouvons
nous pouvons et nous pourrons faire des
choses avec lui et il se présentera lui
à la primaire françois bayrou
imprimé à de l'ump françois bayrou n'est
pas gay et qu'il n'a pas l'intention
fait imprimer en tête baillet
aujourd'hui pour l'instant c'est une
primaire on va dire qu'il est quand même
plutôt organiser ovadia par l'ump et
donc oui non sauf que non il ne se
présentera pas à cette primaire ça
n'aurait évidemment aucun sens en plus
je crois que c'est très important
françois bayrou garde une liberté dans
tout ça dernière question de mieux
cerner ce justement si la droite et le
centre reviennent au pouvoir en 2010 est
est ce que vous allez revenir sur ce
système des régionales et sur les
d'élimination actuelle c'est à dire sur
les 13 régions telles que ça va partir
plus ou moins d'abord je pense qu'il
faudra gouverner plus large
mais pour y aura un espace plus là vous
savez j'étais j'ai été autrefois jeunes
giscardienne giscard disait deux
français sur trois moi je suis à nouveau
pour ces deux français sont 300 sera pas
les réformes
on fera pas les réformes nécessaires
dans le pays la réforme de
l'architecturé de nos départements de
nos externe elle sera nécessaire il faut
qu'on ait quelque chose qui soit plus
lisible que les citoyens s'y retrouvent
jeudi les politiques savent les faire
une nouvelle arche et des faux draps
regarder comment les citoyens ont vécu
ces changements là s'il ya eu du bon
s'il ya eu du moins bon et si a eu du
moins bon mais il faudra changer les
choses pour les citoyens merci merci